l
utilise comme le dit Marie-
Claude Mora.
- Benjamin Hénault travaille
de la maison à temps plein.
- Salut Louis!
- Ingénieur dans
une grande entreprise,
il passe une grande partie de
ses journées en vidéoconférence,
donc sur Internet.
BENJAMIN HÉNAULT,
ingénieur mécanique
- C'est mon outil de travail,
donc il faut une stabilité,
il faut une rapidité aussi.
- Il a d'abord utilisé
les services d'Xplornet avec
une antenne satellite fixe.
- C'était vraiment pas rapide,
c'était pas stablepas stablepast
des problèmes de connexion.
- Il s'est donc tourné vers
Bell Mobilité, plus fiable,
mais beaucoup plus cher.
- Ça fonctionnait très bien,
je me suis jamais plaint
stème-là.
Ça coûtait 300 à 400 $ par mois,
dépendamment de la consommation.
- Depuis décembre,
il se branche au réseau
Starlink, les satellites
d'Elon Musk.
- On n'a pas eu le temps encore.
- L'équipement lui a coûté
au total 820 $, mais sa facture,
qui oscillait entre
300 et 400 $, est passée
à 150 $ par mois.
- On économise 200 $ par mois,
donc un 2400 $ par année.
- Benjamin habite au bout d'un
rang, à Notre-Dame-de-la-Paix.
Il vit donc à la campagne,
mais quand même seulement
à un peu plus d'une heure
d'Ottawa. Au Québec,
250 000 foyers n'avaient
toujours pas accès à Internet
haute vitesse l'hiver dernier,
une situation qui désavantage
les citoyens des régions
rurales, selon ce spécialiste.
RICHARD PARADIS,
président du Groupe CIC
- Ils ont moins d'occasions de
pouvoir participer à l'évolution
de l'économie. Parce qu'ils
pourraient peut-être partir
des services et des produits
r de leur région.
Mais s'ils ont pas l'Internet
haute vitesse, ils sont pas
capables d'interagir avec
le vrai marché du sud.
- Le gouvernement Legault
s'est engagé à corriger
cette inéquité.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
premier ministre du Québec
- C'est que tout le monde
soit branché d'ici 2022.
- La fibre optique sera
utilisée pour la grande majorité
des foyers, mais il faudra
se tourner vers lees
pour brancher les ménages
plus isolés.
- Dans beaucoup de régions, ils
ont vraiment pas de services.
Puis, ce que per
les nouveaux satellites qu'ils
sont en train de développer,
c'est qu'on va pouvoir aussi
offrir un service de téléphonie
mobile dalité.
- SpaceX a lancé jusqu'à
maintenant 2000 satellites
et son réseau Starlink devrait
en compter 12 000 d'ici 5 ans.
De son côté, la canadienne
Télésat compte mettre en orbite
300 satellites. Les premiers
lancements sont prévus dans deux
ans, mais l'entreprise peine
à compléter son financement.
Des retards qui laissent
le champ libre aux concurrents
étrangers.
Ici Marie-Claude Morin,
Radio-C